why do you use four rack story structure
instead of three axe story structure um
because i'm jewish
okay so you know
the four suns the four cups of wine the
four acts it's it's every every passover
we sit at the table and we drink another
cup of wine to each one of the acts i'm
kidding stop it it's a joke okay um but
i wasn't kidding i am jewish the um
i found it to be an easier
way
of of just thinking
it's just
it makes things balanced
you know like three acts you know on a
typical three-act structure it's act two
is twice as long as act one and act
three
so why not just call it four acts
already so you can have like act one act
two a act two b and then you know and
then act three i mean i used to i think
in the early days when i was working on
the system i think that's how i was
calling it then that just felt confusing
so i just went with you know act one two
three and four so it's a four act
structure but it's all the same i mean
it's it's all you know three act
structure i forget who could be true be
there's a six act structure
said fields three acts it's like
you know it's we're all talking about
the same stuff it's really just
here's your pie you're gonna slice it
into eighths or sixteenths or whatever
so
you know and then and then other pieces
of
of my understanding of story structure
played nicely with the
four acts so you know the the four
archetypes
you know things like that so it just
felt like uh forex
made things kind of brought a nice order
to the universe
did anybody fight you on it or no oh
yeah they find people like me all the
time but i mean in terms of didn't they
say that can't be done it's always you
know and you said sure why not why it's
2a to be and no it yeah it's it's like
and every every conversation i have like
that is always
just silly i mean
i mean i i it happens now where like
i'll talk to people who are working on
on like um
tv shows like um
you know even even like a um
like an episode of television where
it's it's
every story's got a beginning a middle
and an end so at the very least you can
subscribe to a three-act structure for
your tv show but people say well but we
don't have commercials so therefore it's
one act
i'm going
okay
if whatever floats you about it all
comes out the same anyway
see i'd like to think that
that the
my understanding of story structure
is not
proscriptive it's descriptive
so i just choose to describe a well-told
story like this somebody else
could choose to describe a well-told
story using different terms and
different terminology i mean everybody
does you know you know blake snyder you
know had you know his way of looking at
a true bee
you know mckee
you know we're all talking about the
same stuff it's not like it's not like
you know if you looked at
you know star wars or
you know avengers end game
you know it's like the movies become
different depending on how you describe
the structure of it all
so
you know so to me it's it's just it's
kind of a semantic
sort of argument just
for my purposes it just it makes things
very orderly um when you look at it in
terms of
sort of the flow of the of a story you
can divide it into quarters
what are plot points and why are they
important
so plot points are
discrete
in my understanding right discrete
chunks of information that add to the
overall knowledge of the story so
so for example um
if we had a um
let's let's say we i'm making i make up
a fictional
movie okay and it's like you know we
come up it's you know the camera
pans
through you know a
manhattan living room in
you know at right after sunrise you know
it's been happening because you can see
the empire state building out the window
and it ends up on and you see like
there's a music stand
you know that as the camera's moving
through this apartment so you know okay
somebody's into music and then there's
an artist's easel so they're into music
and also art and then the camera ends up
in this bedroom and you know and the
alarms go off
you know there are two people in bed and
each has their own alarm set for the
exact same time right and you know and
two hands reach out and shut off the
alarms and
the guy gets out of bed on his side and
the woman gets out of bed on her side
and they go into their bathroom and then
the camera's
finally just either cuts or you know one
continuous movement however you want to
direct it um but we see that they're
brushing their teeth
at two separate sinks and they're really
talking to each other um you know
brushing their teeth at two separate
sinks and then they go have breakfast
together he's reading his newspaper
she's reading her newspaper still not
really talking
you know
she gets up to go to work and they have
a little kiss it even doesn't seem bad
it just seems like it's a kiss goodbye
she goes off to work and um and is
having coffee at some
you know starbucks and she looks over
and there's this couple
clearly in love
okay and she looks at them as they're
hugging and they kiss and she just
bursts out crying
right and there's a old woman next to
her and she goes what's the jerk's name
sweetheart
and she goes ben
right
so
how many plot points was that
it's a true it's a trick question you
say well it's manhattan
it's the the artist easel it's the
you know it's the music stand we saw
them in bed and it's
it's one plot point you know there's
this guy and a girl and their
relationship sucks that's it everything
else about that is
necessary to lay some pipe for the story
who's somebody's into art somebody's
into music they're living together you
know there's no communication going on
but it's all about they julie and ben
let's say her name is julie julie and
ben have a lousy relationship and it's
killing her
right so that says plot point so so plot
points
don't have to be
it's like there's beats there's scenes
you know
then there's plot points so to me a plot
point is you think of like a
like a pearl necklace and plot point is
another pearl
on that necklace
and it's it's not meant to be
and and some plot points could be
you know as just one
one beat but this plot point i described
was basically
i don't know 14 beats something like
that you know it's probably 14 beats if
you i was writing it as a script it's
probably
seven scenes
like the the apartment in the morning
and the breakfast and the you know like
everything would have its own slug line
you know interior julian ben's apartment
bathroom interior julian ben's apartment
kitchen you know or montage but each but
when you shoot it the montages get
broken down into so it's probably seven
scenes in terms of like
strict
movie making how many plot points won
right so
so that became you know that's a big
part of my understanding of story is is
how many plot points does it take to
tell
a complete and ample story as our friend
aristotle might say
um and to me the magic number turned
into 44. there's that four again right
turned into 44. yeah right
and
the whole getting up to 44 was kind of a
weird
sort of exploration anyway and it
doesn't have to be 44 43 47 but if you
tell me you know your typical
you know two hour movie is 85 plot
points it'll be like
i politely disagree it's too much you
know or you're thinking about beats
maybe you know not plot points and also
just just you know for clarity sake
again it's just descriptive right it's
maybe this is the part where i'm
actually getting proscriptive because
i believe very firmly and there's the
the film that gets sold and the film
that gets made
so
i
am obsessed with the film that gets sold
because that's the one that you write
and you try to get people to
fork over money for it
but that's the one you have control over
that's like yours as a writer and and
that's the one that that you can really
influence once you sell it
like if we go back to the stanley's cup
story i had no control once once i sold
it
no control over the direction of the of
the story and how would it get rewritten
and who's going to be in it and what's
the director's take on it
you know so it's like
so i'm i'm
really occupied myself with the
writing a script that could get sold
and
for that you want to
tell a story in a way
that the person
who will buy it
can understand it
and
and that story can kind of get into
their heart and soul
so
to me
44 plot points turned into that's a very
manageable story
and following
you know a kind of a um
a guideline of what does a well told
story look like
um
just
felt to me like that
that enhances your
chances of selling something because
you're telling you're telling a story in
a way that people are kind of programmed
to
hear the story
you know um which is not to say that
people shouldn't do crazy ambitious
stuff and just so you know everything
everywhere all at once
is crazy ambitious doing really well i
haven't examined it to see but i can
almost guarantee you even with all
that's going on
um that it you know that it is hitting
it's it's it's hitting the plot points
in in the right order and in the right
places it just does it with crazy wild
imagination
right so you know so for me it's not
like every it's not like every
good movie or every every popular movie
has to
follow this system but
you know or every movie written or every
movie ever made follows this exact
system it doesn't right but every movie
that that really kind of
sinks in and gets to people
um pretty much
whether it's intentionally or not is
following
something very similar to what i
prescribed